let's bring in the Georgetown head coach
Patrick Ewing congratulations on the big
win last night coach
Thank You Dana and as always it's great
it's always great to be on your show
and I really appreciate that that was a
great a great win for us
I do you know how good your team is well
we're still working progress you know we
have the ability to be a very good team
we just have to be a little bit more
consistent you know you know I thought
that we lost a lot of close games early
in the season and I think that you know
it's gonna help us going down going down
the stretch and also end it in the Big
East tournament but my guys they they
believe in themselves they fight and
they're they're willing to scratch Kalon
do what they need to do to get wins
tougher to play or tougher to coach oh
it's definitely tougher to coach you
know as a player you know you you're the
one out there getting it done you know
now I know why Jeff Jeff Van Gundy used
to be when I see him in the morning I
you know bags under his eyes
Pat Riley starting to lose his hair a
little bit definitely is is definitely
harder tougher to coach tend to play you
know when you're when you're you know
you're the one that as a player you're
the one out there playing as a coach
you're the one that's trying to get the
guys to do the things that you want to
do to help them to win I was wondering
if you find yourself channeling coach
Thompson by saying things that maybe he
said to you when you're 18 or 19 years
of age sometimes sometimes and one of
the things that I've been telling the
guys lately is you know one of the
things that he used to say to us is that
you know at this time of the year those
who can play play you know that meaning
that you got to elevate your game this
is the time of year for you to elevate
your game if you want to make a good
running and in the NCAA tournament make
a good run in the Big East tournament
and you know does one of the things I've
been saying to the guys and then who
came up with the idea of the John
Thompson t-shirts on the bench you like
that
you know it's funny one of one of the
guys that work here for us he's the one
who designed it you know we wanted to
honor you know his Black History Month
we wanted to honor coach Thompson for
all his work that he's done and he came
up with that idea brought it to the
Jordan Jordan Brand folks and they agree
with that they liked it and so we
printed it out and I thought it was a
great hit yeah it was and it's great to
see coach Thompson at the game as well
go back to when you were 18 and if you
can let us know you know how famous you
were and can you see any parallels with
Zion Williamson and that celebrity
nature playing on national TV being a
pretty big deal well you know the
difference is when I was coming up there
wasn't any internet and all that stuff
you know it wasn't any Twitter Facebook
snapchat all these all these things that
that goes goes with the with the
internet there wasn't any of that for me
so that he's larger than life now
anything that he that he does people
could see it in it with it and with an
instant but you know when I was coming
up I was the design with a design
William that was the the number one
recruited athlete you know so all the
only difference is he's more said global
globally known now because of the
internet and I was you know known mostly
in the US but you also I now people are
looking at Zion Williamson getting
injured and saying you know should he
shut it down you know this goes back to
the one in done I don't understand that
what you know so I don't understand and
shut it down you know it's part of the
game you know I understand that you you
try to take precautions you know you
have a bright future ahead of you but so
what is it what's gonna happen if he
gets to the league he's gonna best but
gets banged up he's gonna shut it down
for the year you know i if he's not
hurt you know if it's not if he's not
hurt real bad and he's you know he gets
his treatment he gets back strong get
back healthy and then he got he goes out
and play but you know what's happening
though coaches you have people with
agendas those who want to get rid of the
one-and-done and those who think hey you
know what go to college you're playing
with Coach K it's great exposure helps
your brand and you know so so there's
two sides and people are using this I on
Williamson to further their agendas
people you know as politics you know
that's politics but you know I do agree
that at some point they need to pay the
athletes you know I do believe in that
you know but I don't believe that if he
if he's physically able to play he
should play yeah and you know you look
at his future his potential and and I
was just looking at you know Spike Lee's
down there Spike's already sizing him up
for a Knicks uniform I think do you
think this morning and I said thanks
Mike you didn't go to our game but you
down there and I'm dude watch those guys
play I felt some type of way we are
today but it's the lottery - and here we
go again
you know Ken the Knicks win the lottery
right now what do you think happened in
that lottery the right thing happened I
went to I went to the place I was
supposed to go that you were supposed to
go yes you know it's funny I was I was
working I'm gonna tell you a story you
know everyone has all these theories
about what happened yeah so I was
working for the for the end NBA TV and I
was working a lottery and the gentleman
walked in with all the envelopes so I
went up to him I said which one is the
cold one
you know but you know who doesn't laugh
coach David Stern it's too soon to do
that to the Pacers the commissioner
David Stern does not laugh when you joke
about that lottery you know he's all
business it was it was funny to me no
man but were you ready for New York yeah
I mean you know I believe that all of my
experiences help me or prepare me to you
know to face the the the turmoil or the
order or the fans and sometimes crazy
fans of New York you know and you have
to you have to have tough skin to play
in New York but also you played with the
Big East tournament so you had played in
the gore familiar with that you know so
that I'm sure helped a lot do your kids
ever bring up your YouTube videos there
are highlights did I ever talk about you
your playing days yeah yeah they do
sometimes what are they saying you know
you know I've all the kids that saw me
playing out younger kids who never who
didn't see me play so my little studies
asking me you know why did I play that I
like playing was that good I think he'll
be as good as me I'm like I hope so but
what about your players on Georgetown do
they know they're familiar they you know
most of them you know weren't born when
I was playing on were just born when I
when I was playing but uh you know they
know they they've heard the stories just
tell him to look at a couple of those
games like against Ralph Sampson or
maybe against North Carolina those kind
of things yeah then I realized you're a
nice guy so took I watched those
highlights a little differently now I'm
like you know what
hey congrats so far been a great season
big win and you get Creighton coming up
this weekend are we gonna see you at the
Final Four I'll be there and hopefully
I'll be there playing awfully my team
will be there with me that's my dream
okay well if even if they're not there
you know we'd love to see again yes I
look forward to seeing you dear Dan
thank you buddy that's Patrick Ewing a
Georgetown head coach big win over crate
era Villanova they got Creighton coming
up on Saturday for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]